The third principle of knowledge based AI agents in CS7637 is that reasoning is
typically top-down as well as bottom-up. Ordinarily, we assume that data is
coming from the world and most of the reasoning is bottom-up as we interpret
the data. In contrast to knowledge based AI, low level processing of the data
results in the invocation of knowledge structures from memory. These knowledge
structures then generate expectations, and the reasoning becomes top down.
Frames were an example of this kind of top down reasoning. We had the input,
Angela ate lasagna with her dad last night at Olive Garden. And
the processing of this input led it to the invocation of this particular frame.
Once this frame has been pulled out of memory,
then this particular frame can generate a lot of expectations. For example,
was the object alive when Angela ate it? False. Where is the object now?
Inside the subject. What is the subject's mood after she had dinner?
She was happy. A similar kind of top down generation of expectations occurred
when we used frames to understand simple sentences about earthquakes.
Scripts are another example of this kind of top-down generation of
expectations and expectation based processing. Once we have a script,
then that script generates expectations over the next action.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It tells us what to look for in the world, even before that happens. And
when that doesn't happen, we know an expectation has been violated and we
are surprised. Constraint propagation is another way of thinking about top down
processing. We will input data in the form of pixels representing this cube.
We have to infer that this image, in fact,
is that of a cube. We have knowledge about this constraint of various kind of
junctions that can occur in the world of cubes and this knowledge then generates
expectations of what might be a blade and what might be a fold. This notion of
top-down processing using knowledge structures to generate expectations of
the world in order to be able to interpret data essential to knowledge based AI.
It's also deeply connected with human cognition.
Some current theories of human cognition think of brains as predictive machines.
We are constantly generating expectations, we are constantly making predictions
over the world, that guide our reasoning, that guide our actions.